I just got an
email well the interview is not
happening okay so my interview is to oh
wait no it's not tomorrow it's in two
days but I want to really hone down the
behavior questions I've spent a lot of
time getting to know the company the
company values along with um like
getting my technical just knowledge
really like robust with basically what
they work on so I'm going to really work
on some behavioral questions right now
so
that tomorrow is just a light touchup
and it's not me trying to crank down all
the behavioral the day before the
interview you know what I mean okay it's
Father's Day so my parents came to pick
me up and enjoy the day at their house
so let's pack up and
go
okay oh
hello did you like some
flowers so this is what they make us do
on P
[Laughter]
[Music]
I hope everyone had a good Father's Day
I had a great one with my family as you
saw and now I'm back to work mode my
interview is tomorrow I told myself I
would do behavioral questions in the
first part of the day and then um the
later part of the day I would focus more
on developing using their products to
get more acquainted with the company and
their
teams this afternoon um soon in a little
over an hour I have a quick chat with
one of the workers
there I prefer to wash my face in the
kitchen nowadays my bathroom sink is so
low and I just end up just hunching over
so
much okay for my behavioral questions
I've been using the techin handbook. org
for prep they have a page named most
commonly asked behavioral questions
across top tech companies and these are
really great questions from the basics
of why do you want to work for X company
but also questions like what is
something you had to persevere at for
multiple months and how have you handled
criticism of your work and what I have
found is if you can Master these
questions which is literally 1 through
29 you then have the blueprint for
answering all of their behavioral
questions they also then break it down
per like company so they say Airbnb
software engineer behavioral questions
Amazon bite dance Dropbox hired and it's
all for free it is such an amazing
resource that I really hope yall know
about it's
phenomenal I'm going to start off the
conversation just saying yep I have an
interview for this this and this and you
being a black woman of the company
especially at the location that inter
for I really wanted to hear about what
your experience has been so far in your
career that's one and I'll see
what questions come to me as she's
talking
okay so that was pretty good
um I was a tiny I was a tiny tiny bit
thrown off in the beginning of the call
the beginning of the call cuz they're
busy and I get it they're busy so I
since truly appreciate her putting her
time to talk to me um at the same time I
think just hearing I think that's what
I'm trying to say hearing that
busyness coming through the
call was scary for me I was like oh
okay let me really go through these
questions as fast as possible and get
everything I can but overall I think
that went really well I think that went
really well now that that is done that
was a big part of
today um let me look at my to-do list I
want to well I think I should spend a
little bit of the day relaxing a tiny
bit um but also I think cuz it's 3:13
right now the call lasted just under 11
minutes I think by around 4:35 I'll
start developing with their products
with the company's products of B to
better understand also um their Tech and
whatnot it's interview day it
is
Tuesday June 18th
Happy juneth eve y'all and I am excited
I'm reminding myself over and over that
this is a behavioral
interview or like it likely is
one because it's
literally only 30 minutes
long and it's on the phone it's not even
a video interview it's l literally on
the cell phone she's going to call
me and we're going to have a quick
little chat and it's going to be amazing
last night I ended up
not doing any more prep actually I know
I said I would check
out their developer
tools I was
just so so tired like
not even like sleepy type of tired you
know when you're just mentally
drained I was just very mentally drained
and because I was reminding myself that
this is a 30 minute like recruiter
screen I was like K like you don't even
need
to dive into all that just yet like it's
okay that time will come you don't need
to do it now let's work smarter not
harder
one thing I was struggling with last
night was finding a good answer for the
question what is your biggest
weakness I think most of us all know
that answers don't cut it
anymore you know the ones that are like
oh I'm just such a perfectionist or like
I'm just too much of a team
player like I was like no I need a real
answer that's simply just not that bad
and like I can explain a way type of
thing and I was able to think of one and
I'm very happy I decided to lean on
something I said um two YouTube videos
ago in my video how to build apps in
seven
days or how I build apps in seven days I
don't remember I'll put it right here
but something I said was it is really
ult for me to just conjure up from
nowhere from my own mind the specific
design of certain things I know how like
I want it to look but when it comes to
the specific nuances necessary to make
that a reality that can be very
difficult for me and I said in that
video I said
how because of
that wait
wait hold
on doing some intricate work
here so in my YouTube video I said that
because of that I do a lot of research
regarding the UI and really honing down
how I want it to look through that
process and so yeah I decided to use
that as what's my biggest weakness and
explain
it
[Music]
away I need to find good questions to
ask them I was I forgot saving that for
today let me update the lighting hold on
okay I
think okay I think that's
better okay I think these are my options
for
atire I'm feeling a dress I'm leaning
more towards these
two I'm going to start off with this cuz
it's like it's not like a super hot day
today but it's like yeah it's kind of
cold I'm not going to lie I woke up and
went outside it was kind of cold so let
me try this first I really like
this I've never worn the dress which is
why I'm over here like wow I really like
it I've never worn it I bought it a
couple months ago just off the rack and
yeah I think it's cute okay so this is
what we're going with
today um yeah oh yeah
okay my
interview is four minutes
away and I'm excited I'm excited I'm
excited um yeah it's going to be good
make sure to be a member of this YouTube
channel because then you get to hear the
entire interview with some like alak the
company and whatnot but yes you'll get
to hear all of it let me have my resume
in front of me so I can very easily
refer back to it and like I said it's a
phone call but I wanted to just make
sure I looked good so I felt good felt
confident and that just exuded through
every sweat
gland okay wish me luck just seconds
away we are just seconds away
should get a call any moment
now okay now it's been 2
minutes it is
1:32 let me draft an
email that I might send to her at 135
I'll send it to her it's 133 now okay I
drafted the
email hi I'm very excited to speak with
you about the blanket rooll at blank I
believe our call was scheduled for today
3:30 p.m EST
EST please let me know if this day and
time still works or if you are just
simply delayed or if you are you're just
simp thanks so
much wait I just got an
email
no okay
well the interview is not happening
today she rescheduled it for
Friday okay that's so upsetting that's
so upsetting I'm really upset I'm really
upset I'm really upset I'm really
upset hi I was just about to reach out
yes we can reschedule for that time I
look forward to speaking with you
best hello
yo H what's wrong I'm
mad why are you mad she I'm sitting here
waiting waiting waiting then I get an
email just now saying she needs to
reschedule for
Friday oh
okay yep
as we were talking about this is such a
numbers
game so like how many people are being
interviewed during this time that I
can't speak to her because she has to
Res scheduled for Friday because her
whole week is booked with interviews
she's doing interviews all this week
right I could end up having less time to
prepare for the second interview trying
to like catch up with everyone like
because of that I think I need to start
preparing for like the technical nap
Agreed 100% I mean I would a th% agree
with that I swear if I get to Friday and
they're like sorry we hired someone I'm
gonna I'm gonna jump off I'm I'm gonna
be done okay
Universe what is meant for me will be
for me okay I'll say can you critique
this from me no worries exclamation
point I'm really interested in this role
period if you do end up having time
before Friday please let me know
exclamation point I'm available at any
time this week period can we change the
second period to a
[Music]
semic okay it is now
2:43
p.m. and I have moved on to learning
more about recursion I ended last night
trying to practice some recursion
problems however I kind of don't really
know much about it other than the
general concept and so decided today
this afternoon to really focus in on
building that knowledge and I'm actually
really happy with myself because I can
already see myself improving that's like
the best feeling to me like something
that like you couldn't even wrap your
head around now you can wrap your hand
and also kind of like maneuver a little
bit um I actually bought a course
yesterday um what what was the course
the course is Master the coding
interview by Andre Nei on
udemy I appreciate what the course is
trying to do however I think I just am a
person who learns best and fastest with
just handson problem solving and I feel
like the course is just like too base
level for the type of quick learning for
a tech interview that I'm trying to do
like they cover everything from beginner
data structures and explaining Big O and
whatnot all the way down to the more
complex stuff and I skipped over the
beginner um items like a raise to get to
like linked list and I feel like
everything was just so surface level I
don't really like that and that's really
how I spent most of my morning and so
with the afternoon I was like you know
what let me go back to just doing what I
was doing last night which is getting
that hands- on practice I really hope
that by the end of today I can feel more
confident in recursion and can move on
to I'm thinking trees tomorrow but also
guess what my interview is
tomorrow the interview that was supposed
to be yesterday yeah it is tomorrow
morning and so I'm going to try to just
end this this as soon in the evening as
possible I'm thinking like 6:00 p.m. I
can finish 600 p.m. 7:00 p.m. that way I
can get the rest I need to wake up and
have a really good interview so yeah I'm
glad I can finally fingers crossed film
that for y'all tomorrow and tell y'all
how that goes because remember I'm doing
these technical interview prep right now
for an interview that I don't even have
yet I haven't even secured yet because I
haven't even gone through the first
interview the the round one screening
call so yes fingers crossed um I hope
you all had a really good juneth like I
hope you got to love on yourself love on
your community and just yeah hopefully
you also got the day off yeah it's a
Federal holiday so I hope you got the
day off so no this is my
day it's interview day it is 8:17 in the
morning Thursday morning and I have well
no not 8:17 I just looked at my phone
it's 8:19 so I have about 10 11 minutes
before my interview so no I'm going to
set up just as I did before and yeah
take it and crush
it okay ready we are just one minute
away
now so
let's get get
it okay it's
8:31 I think I've ever been this nervous
for a screening
call we're prepared so
much it's
8:32
8:33 it's
8:34 it's
8:35 oh hello this is Nia hey Nia this
is calling I'm so sorry I was running a
little behind today is now still a good
time to chop yes
[Music]
absolutely okay that was super simple I
didn't have to do it I have a second
interview it looks like yeah okay
perfect
okay taking out the garage to go to work
no the interview went really well it was
pretty
basic
um it's like cuz it was just 30 minutes
on the phone with the recruiter so like
I I felt like it would be yes so I felt
like it would be pretty chill just kind
of like checking like my qualifications
and if I'm a good fit you know what I
mean and yeah no that's exactly what it
was was and by the end of the interview
she said she would move me to the next
round um which is a 1-hour technical
interview and like